et dans ce même sondage ipsos emmanuel
macron est largement en tête des
intentions de vote au premier tour au
second il est donné vainqueur face à
valérie pécresse et marine le pen une
tendance qui s'explique selon bruno
bonnell député lrm du rhône par la
reconnaissance des français du travail
du gouvernement face une opposition à
court d'idées
évidemment que je crois que les français
reconnaissent ils travail qui est
effectué par le gouvernement il veut
plutôt satisfaisant ceci dit on a une
opposition qui est concerté qui est
d'ailleurs à droite très lourde plus
émietté à gauche qui effectivement pour
le mans peine à trouver des arguments
crédibles de gouvernement et je crois
que c'est ça tu es français entendent
dans ces sondages donc quelque part
c'est pas c'est pas en tant que telle la
gestion de la crise sanitaire c'est
l'organisation d'un gouvernement qui a
anticipé un simple nombre de choses qui
a su réagir également aux événements
inattendus face à finalement des
promesses électorales sur des sur des
points particuliers dont certains
d'ailleurs ont déjà été adressées par
notre gouvernement est qui et qui
probablement son frustrant parce que il
n'y a pas d'idées nouvelles c'est
surtout ça qui se passe il n'y a pas
d'idées nouvelles dans l'opposition
aujourd'hui